they're doing a what if
uh animated series for marvel uh which
is like you know um
did they ask you to do anything yeah no
i'm in it i i've i've been doing it
okay so that's what i wanted to know um
yeah what what when they presented that
to you was it one of these things how
early on did you know
that like how early on did they ask you
to do it and is it one of these things
where you sort of trust
marvel implicitly and you're like okay
whatever you need i'm doing it
yeah look look it's like you know if the
president calls and says i want you to
come to the white house you don't ask
why you just kind of get on a plane and
go to the white house
when marvel you know ca called my agents
called and said they're doing this thing
what if and this
they have four or five episodes planned
out you can do it all
i'm like whatever whatever i don't i
don't care what the money it doesn't
matter yes i'm going to do it absolutely
all day every day got it uh
did you record everything in one day
those four or five episodes i recorded
in
one day or two days and now
uh i think i have to go in february to
record a few more
i loved the what if comic when i was
growing up loved
um how familiar are you or were you with
the what if comics
and when you're recording how much are
they showing you
on a screen in terms of like the
animatics or like what it's going to
look like and how much is it just sort
of
reading off the page you're just kind of
interpreting it yourself and reading off
the page and trying to stay into the
character of
of crossbones and uh they set up the
scenario
and uh and we just kind of play around
and uh until we get it
and and it's uh and then they show a
little bit sometimes but you know marvel
they don't want to show you too much
because especially me i'm a big mouth
and they
i've been scolded many times
i don't think you're going to get
scolded any more than uh ruffalo for
live streaming
on his phone right you know i think
that's going to ultimately be the top of
the the [ __ ] up list
yeah you know look i recorded that like
probably almost a year ago
and you know i'm sure with covert and
everything everything was put on hold
uh but now it's come back around and i i
literally don't know anything more about
it than i just
you know i don't even remember what i
was doing i don't even remember what i
said
in when i end the shows but i think it's
going to be my
my little guy my son rio is not so
little he's 13.
uh i mean he's a crazy marvel he can't
wait to see it he can't wait